a career in cloud computing is a dynamic
and promising Choice with diverse roles
continuous learning and Global
opportunities Cloud professionals are in
high demand with skills in Cloud
architecture devops and security as per
data from market and Market the global
cloud computing Market was valued at 546
billion dollars in 2022 and it is
projected to reach
1240 billion dollars by 2027 with cagr
of 18 the field offers room for growth
encourages problem solving and comes
with ethical responsibilities in an
ever-evolving industry today we will
discuss the top highest paying jobs in
cloud computing their roles and
responsibilities and how much these
roles earn but before we begin consider
subscribing to Simply learn and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
us
I never look back
and simply learn to get ahead Jessica
Danish a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply learn
why are you possible
with a course from a premier University
[Music]
true champion who upskilled to win big
how big a massive hike that transformed
my life Danish change gears pretty early
in the race
but Russian wanted to explore more to
get ahead
simply learned from mechanical
engineering to a data analyst and a
podcaster in his free time Essa career
transformation
industry expertsika live
it felt like a piece of cake that is
simply awesome what's also awesome is
that no salt
nitin didn't choose a quick fix
each started data science into the mix
nitin how did you change the game worked
on real industry problems to become the
real deal a joint family a regular job
responsibilities but nothing could stop
nithin from getting ahead what an
all-rounder de Hoya Knight with flexible
learning you can always make it right
bashing your situations
[Music]
the number one on the list is cloud
architect
a cloud architect's primary
responsibility involves crafting and
implementing a comprehensive framework
that governs the operation of all Cloud
Technologies their rule extends to
devising the overarching cloud computing
strategies for a company ensuring that
cloud performance aligns seamlessly with
the established framework they are
instrumental in ensuring the smooth
operation of companies Cloud
infrastructure adhering to budget
constraints while ensuring efficiency by
overseeing the cloud environment Cloud
Architects guarantee Optimal Performance
and seamless integration of cloud
services their expertise and guidance
Empower companies to harness full
potential of cloud computing while
maintaining cost Effectiveness and
operational efficiency given the
complexity of their work and their
integral role within the company Cloud
Architects typically command a
substantial average salary of hundred
and thirty thousand dollars
on that note if you are an aspiring
Cloud architect then get certified with
Cloud architect Masters program by
simply learn the curriculum of this
course is aligned with Microsoft Google
cloud and AWS so what you will learn
with this program the cloud architect
certification program is designed to
make you an expert in Cloud applications
and architecture it will enable you to
master the core skill set required for
Designing and deploying dynamically
scalable highly available fault tolerant
and reliable applications on top three
Cloud platform providers like Amazon web
services or AWS Microsoft Azure and
Google Cloud platform the program will
give you an in-depth understanding of
cloud services such as AWS cloud
formation Azure resource manager ec2 S3
Route 53 VPC Azure app service
gcp and more you will acquire the
Knowledge and Skills for passing Cloud
architect certifications such as AWS
architect an Azure architect you will
also have access to 60 plus live
instructor-led online classrooms 100
plus hours of self-paced video content
simulation exams a community moderated
by expert and other resources that
ensure you follow the optimal path to
your desired rule of cloud architect the
course includes 16 class real world
industry projects that let you work way
through the technical challenges
associated with cloud computing this
course is suitable from beginners to
experience level however one years of
experience is always preferred use the
coupon code ytb E15 to get instant
discount on your purchase so what are
you waiting for hurry up find the course
Link in the description box
moving to the next highest paying job on
the list which is cloud developer Cloud
developers design and build Cloud native
applications integrate cloud services
ensure security optimize performance and
automate deployment they collaborate
with teams monitor applications and stay
updated on the evolving Technologies to
create efficient and scalable Cloud
Solutions the salary range for cloud
developers typically Falls between
ninety thousand dollars two hundred and
forty thousand dollars reflecting the
high demand for their expertise on
number three we have Cloud automation
engineer
the role of cloud automation engineer
revolves around overseeing and
implementing automated systems for an
organization this role encompasses
responsibilities such as building
maintaining and deploying automated
systems this technological advancement
proves beneficial in minimizing the need
for human resources to engage in
repetitive tasks Cloud automation
Engineers earn a respectable average
salary of hundred and twenty thousand
dollars with potential increases as
individual enhance their skill sets and
gain valuable experience on number four
we have Cloud engineer
Cloud Engineers design and manage Cloud
infrastructure automate tasks enhance
security optimize performance control
costs and ensure compliance the
collaborate with teams troubleshoot
issues and plan for scalability while
staying updated on evolving Technologies
the average salary of a cloud engineer
is reported to be 92 000 last but not
the least a number five we have Cloud
administrator the cloud administrators
manage Cloud infrastructure focusing on
resource allocation security cost
control and compliance they monitor
troubleshoot and optimize systems while
ensuring the data integrity and disaster
recovery
Automation and capacity planning are
also the part of their responsibilities
the salary for cloud Administration can
range from sixty thousand dollars to
ninety thousand dollars with an average
annual salary of sixty seven thousand
dollars so hey aspiring Cloud experts
certifications always add value to your
career and for that being said have a
look at Caltech cloud computing bootcamp
by simplylearn the current cloud
computing bootcamp offers comprehensive
training in Azure and AWS empowering
participants to excel in cloud computing
this online bootcamp provides a deep
dive into Cloud architecture principles
equipping individuals with the expertise
required to become Cloud professionals
check the complete course details from
the link in the description box before
we wrap up this session listen to what
our Learners say about our courses in
their own words finishing the course led
to personal recognition and open the
door for even more artificial
intelligence projects and it came with
significant pay raise my hand hi I'm
Phillip I'm 61 years old and last year's
I have skilled with simple enforcement
program in cyber security I'm happy to
tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and ccsp certification
exam on the first attempt after taking
course we decided to make a course in
devops from Simply learning the course
is very beneficial for both our careers
yeah I got a promotion after the course
and I go to handle Community company at
first I would like to learn from YouTube
then apply for your job foreign
because of its tremendously High waiting
to be rated as one of the best Education
portal online worldwide is truly
promising I switched to a new world as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confident Boost alongside numerous
other possible outcomes and with this we
conclude the top 5 highest paying Cloud
jobs in 2024. if you found this
information valuable please consider
sharing with your friends and don't
forget to subscribe to stay updated with
simply learn stay tuned with simply
learn until we meet again thanks for
watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign